[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensored a
Global TV exclusive she's the woman who
took Prince Harry's virginity behind a
Countryside Pub Sasha Walpole kept Harry
singer for 21 years and all was intended
to but he told his truth about it in his
Memoir so tonight Sasha tells me hurts
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening London welcome
to Piers Morgan uncensored Prince
Harry's turned his back on a family in a
nation that adored him he was a lovable
Rogue his childhood heartbreak United
the country in Goodwill we're all very
proud of him as he served in the British
army we cheered his wedding celebrated
the Glamorous biracial future of the new
monarchy he had it all Harry but he's
burned most of it to the ground charged
by bitterness and resentment his way
he's warned his family by selling the
lurid story of his private life to a
media industry he says he hates for
invading his private life and that's at
the heart of why I think the public here
have grown a bit tired of Harry they
view him as a hypocrite he spews his
truth to the highest bidders whilst
repeatedly demanding privacy he rails
against his family for sharing details
of their conversations while exposing
family secrets and family feuds in books
and interviews for millions of dollars
he's reinvented himself as a big kind
feminist mental health campaigner while
showing blatant disregard for anyone
other than himself nothing better sums
it up the decision to tell the story of
losing his virginity in his Memoir spare
I suspected he was referring to my
recent loss of virginity in glorious
episode with an older woman she liked
horses quite a lot and treated me not
unlike a young stallion quick ride after
which she'd smack my rump and set me off
to graze among the many things about it
that were wrong it happened in a grassy
field behind a busy Pub
well that story triggered an inevitable
Avalanche of speculation actually Liz
Hurley had to deny reports it was her as
to the chief executive of Cotswold
airport Susanna Harvey and his former
lover Catherine Omni and Polo coach Emma
Tomlinson among others just last weekend
the actor Rupa Everett said he knew who
it was and he thought it had happened at
a ski chalet well Harry knew that he'd
ignited fever conjecture but still chose
to unpin that grenade and walk away and
the unfair speculation about innocent
people is why Sasha Walpole has now
thought obliged to tell her a story she
kept Harry's secret for 21 years but
he'd have to with no choice for all his
bleating about privacy Harry simply
didn't bother to worry about hers he
didn't think about how writing in
Florida detail about losing his
virginity my upset Sasha a children her
husband her parents her friends Sasha on
the other hand has treated Harry with
unwavering respect she'd have taken the
story to the Grave if he'd allowed it to
she could have sold a story any time in
the last two decades as he's sold his
but she chose not to she behaved with
decency discretion and Duty which
ironically are the very qualities we
expect of our Royals the late Queen did
that so masterfully King Charles does it
too so Prince William Princess Kate
Harry is the Rogue Royal but not quite
so lovable anymore we now know that the
older woman Sasha is actually younger
than his wife Meghan Markle she speaks
affectionately about Harry even now and
recalls humble Tales of youthful frolics
of rural pubs it'll be familiar to
millions of British people she drives
three ton diggers works on Guardian
patios and leads an honest life with her
family in Wiltshire one was pretty
private actually and certainly worlds
away from a luxury Californian pedestal
from which the Privacy preaching Prince
shoots his poison darts back at his
family in brim but it's actually people
like Sasha Waller represent The Very
Best of British values sadly I'm not so
sure that can be said about Harry
anymore
well
Sasha Walpole joins me now
a week ago I'd never heard of you no not
anybody else from your family and
friends and now you're like this
globally known person and actually
through no fault of your own or desire
to be publicly known at all no I know
it's been a bit of a whirlwind week and
hopefully it's a means to an end and I
can get back and back to normality go
back to work drive my Digger hide back
under my rock how do you feel about the
way this has all exploded in your life
um very surreal still doesn't seem real
um
to know kind of shocked really I didn't
think that it would hit the headlines
like it did I mean there's a lot of
worse stuff going on in the world right
now that probably needs more of a focus
whereas we had the earthquake
um and a few other things going on the
war in Ukraine and
but yeah I never thought it would
happen like it has
I mean it's been a fascinating thing to
watch on Phil because I used to run
National newspapers so I knew exactly
what would happen the moment Harry put
in this book the details of how he lost
his virginity to an older woman in a
field behind the back of a pub I just
thought well I know what's happening now
every single news desk in fleestry and
every TV network they're all sending
people off to try and find this poor
woman who is probably never said a word
about this and now is going to be on the
front page of papers from here to
America to China to Timbuktu
yeah it is I mean I had a bit of a
running with the paparazzi back in 2001
um so I kind of knew how it can turn out
um
and at first I was a bit like nope just
hide it'll be fine it'll go away like I
have done you know in the past and then
suddenly realized that it's getting
closer your world's getting smaller
um a lot more people are talking about
it
um you know friends from back home are
getting questioned accused and I was
just like you know what the way to stop
it is just come forward and say it's me
and then hopefully no sooner it's come
out it'll go and I can carry on with my
little life when was the first moment
that you knew that you were in this book
um when my friend sent me a screenshot
of a comment
um via what what's happened I was just
that way so for watching telly and yeah
I kind of didn't quite know what to do
about it we had we shocked were you I
was scared about what may happen to you
or um disbelief disbelief you went into
so much detail um because then it's
obvious who it was so for me that was
like a huge thing because then said I
was like oh no everyone's gonna know
um and then yeah next day all the
messages started I'm trying to imagine
what it must be like when we played the
clip of Harry I don't know if we can
play it again but we played the clip of
Harry talking about this I just want to
sort of look at you as you listen to
this because I'm trying to imagine what
it was like to have been you yeah when
he came out with this not just in
written word but also in spoken word
this is a guy who's sixth in line or bit
in line to the to the throne of this
country talking about losing his
virginity to to you yes Sasha wall
buyers take a listen
I suspected he was referring to my
recent loss of virginity in glorious
episode with an older woman she liked
horses quite a lot and treated me not
unlike a young stallion quick ride after
which she'd smack my rump and sent me
off to graze among the many things about
it that were wrong it happened in a
grassy feel behind a busy Pub
what did you feel when you you heard
this I don't really know I can see the
humor side of the horse because
obviously
well not at the time
um but I I was agreeing
um I had left High Grave by the time
this had happened right but yeah I just
I don't know I could see the funny side
to it you know
we were two friends and for me I still
see him as Harry I still see him as a
friend that I used to hang out with down
the pub
um you know go and watch the polo with
and yeah it was just seeing pictures of
you of you both there with some other
friends clowning around and stuff I mean
I suppose that my response to it when I
first heard about this was I thought it
was breath I've got to be honest
breathtakingly hypocritical as someone
who goes on and on about privacy to then
reveal such a private thing but not just
about himself but to inevitably spark
the trail of interest that would lead to
your door without even having the good
grace to let you know he was doing it
yeah
I mean if if you want to live a private
life and you want to get out of the the
Limelight and leave the royal family or
whether to live your life as you want to
live it
um to then sell a book and go on Netflix
is kind of going against what you're
saying you want
um but yeah I just have nobody he didn't
call you or not nobody contacted you to
say you're in the book no the First
Union was a friend whatsapping you yep
to say well this is you yeah yeah were
you like oh my God I was yeah well I
think I've probably used A Little Bit
Stronger language I almost fell off my
sofa but yeah it was just you know and
then obviously all the jokes come in
about all young Stallion and the older
lady and I mean tell me what language he
used that I thought was actually quite
disrespectful it was kind of like it was
all wrong you're an older woman treating
him like a stallion it was all yeah I
think it's just the way that it's
written you know the thing wrong about
it we were two friends it should never
have happened we crossed the line it was
never intentional there was nothing
before nothing after
um
I mean Inglorious it's not really that
glorious sleeping with someone in a
field behind a pub
yeah sometimes
would you agree it was Inglorious then
um you know there is nothing glorious
about being drunk and then coughing off
with one of your mates in the field I
don't know actually Sasha I did that
loads of times when I was young almost
felt pretty glorious at the moment it
was the next morning there was a problem
yeah I think that's probably what we all
found
let's go back I want to go back to where
it all started because it's kind of
fascinating that you were you've been a
groom at Highgrove like you said but you
frequented this local pubs there were
two pubs in there so tell me about the
two pubs yeah I mean we used to drink at
the rattle bone quite a lot which is
obviously mentioned quite a lot
um and then we used to go to the vine
tree and there was another one the vine
tree was the crime scene yep that's
where the uh the crime took place yep
but you would go in these pubs and it
was perfectly normal that Harry and
William in fact who was in the pub
actually on my night in question but
they would both come down as young
princes and they'd hang out with you
guys yeah I mean I don't even think
it's like I said before it was just a
group of friends so it didn't matter if
you're a prince a rider a groom a polo
player we were just like we had horses
in common and we just hung out any other
Royals go in there
um not really I think Zara may have
popped in once or twice but it was just
mainly William Harris that was their
local no sign of Uncle Andrew no sign of
Uncle Andrew
does what a problem with me yeah um but
but the so the atmosphere was very
relaxed even though they were Royals and
you were the Royal groom or had been and
the others were just local it didn't
really matter what what class you were
from no part of society they didn't care
no one cared no at the end of the day
you can't be a polar player without a
groom because if you haven't got someone
doing your horses you can't play polo
right and it's the same puzzle I grew up
in a pub pubs are pretty you know
egalitarian places like anything goes
right yeah it doesn't matter whether
you're rich you're poor you're this
you're that it doesn't matter everyone
just mixes in in a pub yeah yeah it is
and you know I I generally look back on
my years of teenage and young adulthood
of fond memories yeah good fun a laugh
you know luckily it was before any
social media and you know camera phones
well now it wouldn't happen probably
because there'd be too many phones out
yeah the Royals would I mean sad for
them but you know you wouldn't better go
to a local pub like that probably no it
is you know
you think he probably did have one of
the better times growing up because he
hasn't grown up with social media he
isn't grown up with a camera phone in
his face was he like them as I said he
was 16. so what would you like
definitely you know fun Sparky he was
just one of the boys he was you know he
was a lad and he was good fun to be
around yeah I mean this he was 16 which
was just been a few years after
obviously his mother died in this
terrible tragedy had you known him in
the aftermath of that no I didn't I
didn't get to know him sort of until a
bit later on from that and to be fair he
never ever sort of spoke about it he you
know he just he just kept it
light-hearted we were just mates we just
talked about Polo horses going to the
pub
and you become sort of quite good
friends well he would ring up your home
yeah and he'd text you and stuff yeah
yeah generally if sometimes you ring the
landline and your mum would answer me
what did he call himself just Harry yeah
yeah Harry and yeah and then we have a
chat and then probably arranged to meet
up somewhere go and watch the polo see
what everyone else was doing see what
the plan was make it sound perfectly
normal why did your mum feel that Prince
Harry was ringing a daughter I don't
know I think because they knew that we
all hung out in a group and it wasn't
really a big thing back home
um yeah I think the first time we did it
she was a bit like what was that Harry
Harry and I was like yeah she's oh how
funny and that was about it really I
mean did you call him H like his wife
doesn't it
um no only in text messages maybe used
to sign off as H but I just thought
that's because you couldn't be bothered
to write Harry
and from what I could gather a lot of
drinking went on this Pub yeah I mean
well the knight in question I I read
that you'd had 10 shots is that right we
did between us it was a bit of a funny
night it was the night before my
birthday so I was actually 18. um but
yeah and I think and you'd had a
difficult problem because you've broken
up with this guy and he then rocks up in
the pub with his new girlfriend yeah
well he rocked up and then she rocked up
after and I think when she rocked up he
could sense that I was a bit oh that's
pretty crap so he then was like come on
let's you know light in the mood have a
laugh you know
um yeah and like I say it just what was
the shots
um I think it was a mixture if I'm
honest I don't think it was one was a
creamy one so I assume it was Bailey
yeah oh my God Bailey's Bailey's whiskey
sambuca really all going down yeah yeah
so he was a shoulder to cry on he
think I mean I'm not one
for attention so I just kind of get on
with things but um yeah I just think
that he sensed that you know I'd not be
okay with that and
um sort of try just to lighten the mood
and have a laugh change change it's not
something he would do on a regular basis
um I think he generally was just trying
to make me and he had a birthday card
for you he did which he'd hand written
yeah we got it here I think and it said
dear sash have a very happy birthday and
don't get too pissed luckily I'll be
there to keep an eye on you loads of
Love bads yeah why do they call
themselves I have no idea but he always
used to sign himself off in different
ways H baz P.S thanks for everything
what do you think you meant by that is
just as friends really I don't think
there's anything specific behind it
we're just talking chatting but nothing
about anything in particular I think he
was just a nice comment to put in a card
it was also a toy that he gave me it was
yeah what was it Miss Piggy why I think
he won it at the thought part that day
and just thought it'd be quite nice to
give it to you he won a prize and then
just decided to re-gift it yeah pretty
much yeah but that's a relationship with
us there was nothing I wouldn't even
expect a card or a Teddy it's just come
and celebrate and have a laugh at what
moment on that night
did things take a turn um
um well because you're great friends you
have been very interested we stuck out
for a cigarette
um and yeah just right hold it there
okay we're gonna take a break and come
back I want to leave it on that dead
what happens after the cigarettes back
with more about my intuitive interview
with Sasha Walpole after the break
cliffhanger
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
well she's the older woman who took
Prince Harry's virginity in a field
behind a pub
Sasha Walpole kept Harry Seeker for 21
years and then Harry told his truth in
his explosive Memoir that included her
so now as Sasha's turn to tell her truth
and a Global TV exclusive she'll join me
on Piers Morgan uncensored and I
guarantee the interview will last a
little longer than Harry did
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel note
what are you uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speech writers here but we do and
I promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to my exclusive interview
with Prince Harry's first lover Sasha
Walpole so just to repeat is only doing
this because of him putting it in his
books Bear all about this night at the
pub
um so let's cut to the quick you're
having a little crafty bag out the back
yep what happened who makes the move
um he made move really yeah
um yeah I don't even really know why or
what happened we just want a cigarette
and then if we know it it was all
happening what was happening
um well he just started kissing me and
then before you know it it was all going
on you start kissing are you thinking
this is weird because you've been really
good friends here's Prince Harry yeah I
mean
I didn't see him as Prince Harry I see
him as Harry as a friend and I think
that's like quite a big difference
um and we were quite drunk so you just
yeah
yep and then you get lost in the moment
and then before you know it it's yeah
and then you wake up and Bob we've
actually got nothing to get out of the
field yeah we get up and then this
reality kicks in yeah we're moving a bit
too fast here so you go from smoking out
the back of the pub to a field nearby
yeah any any particular reason or just
um
Joe the way of people I think is
very pretty guys with that right
he's in the car park
we had gone over events to have a
cigarette away from everyone because he
wasn't really meant to be smoking
um so yeah we just hopped over the fence
seemed like a good idea at the time and
the next thing I mean did you know as
you were
in flagrante in the field that he was
actually a virgin no I didn't no I don't
know why but I didn't even think about
it because it's never been on my mind
before when did you find out was it
actually was it only really confirmed by
the book no well I suppose 100 but I
yeah you kind of people talk and then
the next day was apparent that yeah it
was his first you were the chosen one I
was indeed yes
does it feel weird talking about it it
does because it's just something that
happened so long ago and to me it's not
a big deal I just yeah it's one of those
things it's quite a big deal it is in
the eyes of people yeah I suppose but um
like I said I just seen him as a friend
and if anything is just you've
overstepped that line with a friend the
entire uh Collision lasted five minutes
yeah probably at the higher end of
expectation for men of that age I would
think when they lose their virginity but
um what happened was it awkward
afterwards he went back to the pub right
um yeah we kind of was like oh okay um
we decided to go separate ways so he
went one way I went the other trying to
make it look less obvious but it doesn't
really work where were the security guys
is there at that point they had realized
that he hadn't come out the pubs it was
closing time and yeah they were looking
for him and found him down the road I
think did they ask what had been going
on no no he was kind of taken off and I
went home so you left your belt in the
field I did yeah I had to go back the
next day when I collected my cards to
retrieve my belt and when you saw your
friends when you would go back to the
pub yeah what did you say to them
um nothing there was quite a few giggles
and they kind of knew what had happened
and I think they probably knew what was
going on when
um the security had started looking for
him
um but yeah they just no one really said
anything I think everyone was just a bit
like keep quiet and carry on you wake up
in the morning you presumably quite
hungover yep and then is there that
moment where you suddenly go oh god I've
just remembered yeah
the cringe factor that Creeps in and
you're like oh no I've well and truly
overstepped the Mark
um yeah what did you think to do then I
mean anything did you try and contact
him no I thought I just need to go in
get my car I probably had to go to work
or get ready for work the next day so I
just wanted to get all my stuff it's my
birthday so I probably had plans that
day
um did you who did you tell about what
had happened uh
um I told my sister
and I told my mum and how do they react
friends
okay they didn't really phase my sister
died yeah
yeah but they knew it was Harry they
weren't thinking immediately Royal
Wedding the balcony scene we're on it I
think we're quite far from The Royal
Wedding
um but yeah no I think yeah my sister
you know she found it quite amusing
quite funny
um my mum you know she was just like oh
okay and yeah as long as I was safe and
happy and not in any trouble did your
dad know
um
do you know I think I I brushed the
comment over but he would probably be
like not listening and it's not
something that I'm gonna go and make him
listen to I just want to be like yo yo
Harry and wandered off out the door I
was like I'm not gonna sit him down and
make him listen to what his 19 year old
daughter had done
um so yeah
I mean the weird part of the story for
me is that you then have no more contact
with harrietor having had this
friendship which then builds to this you
know thrilling to new moth that's it you
never see or speak to him again no we
haven't we haven't I you know there's no
messaging there was nothing weird you
think I think it's because foot and
mouth with rice that summer you know and
I think the Social Circles they weren't
happening as much because the polo
wasn't Polo wasn't happening nothing was
happening everything was grounded
everything was stopped
um I had gone you didn't naturally see
each other no no the you know in the
normal group of people that would have
been buzzing for the summer weren't here
um and at that point I then went to a
different nightclub we went over to
Oscars at Longley and I met my husband
there
um you know we got on and then my Social
Circles moved to a different area did
you tell your husband I did yes um
well he kind of knew because it was not
long after all the the pictures came out
and 2001 so it's kind of all around the
same time he didn't really care
yeah he was a face
I mean it's fascinating to me that this
is 21 years ago and that the last you
ever see of Prince Harry is immediately
after you've just had sex with it yeah I
know strange it's sort of random isn't
it it is I mean I don't know
awkward
um you know it's two friends that cross
the line and it is always going to be a
little bit awkward but if it's your
first time then you're probably finding
it a little there would have been a lot
of people Sasha in your position because
you weren't from a wealthy family no
right you've never had huge riches or
anything
um a lot of people might have been
tempted to have cashed in on their night
of lust with Prince Harry you never did
why
because he was a friend
he was a friend I didn't see it like
that and you kind of feel protective
um not because of who he is but I'm like
that with all my friends
um but yeah I just
never occurred never crossed your mind
no not really but that's a decency
that's quite rare actually these days
yeah well you just some things are just
better left unsaid I mean there's an
army isn't it there's you
being decent and wanting to protect him
and his privacy yeah and yet it's only
come out because he actually did the
complete opposite in the book yeah yeah
I know it's um
you go back to the same thing of you
know if you if you want privacy don't
write about it don't speak about it
um but I don't know why he put it in his
book is it hypocritical do you think a
little bit yeah if I'm honest you know
it's something that he could have if
he'd just put oh oh you know about me
losing my virginity and left it at that
it would have been fine because none
wouldn't be none the wiser is the fact
that he added more to that story that
everyone was like huh that's you right
um and then it puts you in that position
so and it must be I mean a range of
emotions but one of them it must be
quite intimidating to be on the
receiving end of suddenly knowing you're
in this book which is one of the biggest
selling books in history yeah and
everyone's reading it and the media are
getting more and more excited about who
this person is and you know it's you
yeah so the clock is ticking to that
knock on the door it is yeah and it's
like
it's one of those at first you're in
denial you're like no I don't you know
it's going to be fine it'll pass over
and like I say the messages start coming
in everyone's starting talking about it
which then pretty much doubles says what
triples the people that know because
then everyone's like oh I know who that
was and for you know people are asking
you know family and friends oh yeah we
know who it is and then suddenly it's
just the reality of this isn't going to
go away forever this is going to flare
up until they know who it is they're
going to be questioning people and yes I
could not have said anything but then
it's never going to stop this is do you
think you should have had the the
matters honestly to just have let you
know it was going to be you could have
given me heads up of like you know I'm
going to put it in the book
um even if he didn't ask if it was okay
just at least give me an option of what
to do about it yeah yeah pretty much
let's take another break I want to come
back I want to get your view I don't
know what you think of the monarchy at
the royal family of the the late great
Queen King Charles and what do you think
about Megan and Harry now living this
life over in California what do you feel
about them because Sasha Wilborn now we
want to know your views
we'll be back after the break but more
from my exclusive interview
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
well she's the older woman who took
Prince Harry's virginity in a field
behind a pub
Sasha Walpole kept Harry Seeker for 21
years and then Harry told his truth in
his explosive Memoir that included her
so now it's Sasha's turn to tell her
truth
and a Global TV exclusive she'll join me
on Piers Morgan uncensored and I
guarantee the interview will last a
little longer than Harry did
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no word
of you every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
well welcome back uh Sasha Walpole who
took Prince Harry's virginity is still
with me those words every time you hear
that must be weird right what did your
family make of it when it all blew up in
the last like two weeks um they're quite
calm quite sort of okay my mum you my
dad didn't it wasn't until I had a bit
of a conversation with him it became
apparent he had no idea what I was on
about and then I spoke to mum and was a
bit like well I don't think Dad knows
and she's
I'll just check and she's like no he
didn't know
um which was really awkward I mean
Hartford any dad but then his daughter's
all over the front page of the paper for
taking Prince Harry virginity there's
quite a moment to wake up to that
vehicle yeah especially when you know
it's your daughter at first you're just
thinking oh well okay and then when you
realize it's someone you know and love
it's a bit different but was he annoyed
at Harry no he wasn't I mean they're
massively supportive in their main
concern is I'm happy I'm safe
um they said they'll support me either
way whether I was to speak out or
whether advice to keep it a secret
either way they would try and do damage
limitation and just you know be there
for me your kids are too young they're
only five and three but how did your
husband react to it all being public
I think he was as shocked as me
obviously he knew about it so it was no
great big secret but um if he didn't
know it would have been probably really
awkward but yeah I think the fact that
he knew he just kind of laughed and was
like oh what we're gonna do it's been an
amazing you know two years really for
the monarchy really since I think Prince
Philip died and then the queen died and
we've now got the coronation coming are
you are you a big monarchist I am yeah I
do like a royal family yeah what do you
make of what's been going on with them I
think sad I think it's sad with any
family regardless if you're a Royal or
whoever as soon as there's a bit of
conflict in between family it's sad it
is sad I'm lucky I have a good family
and I have you know my sister's amazing
so we're all really close
um so I couldn't really imagine how they
would feel especially for you I mean
being in the pub with William and Harry
you've seen them young and obviously
very close then yeah particularly
probably the closest they've been was in
the aftermath of their mother's death to
see them now completely having this Rift
and completely apart that is really sad
I think it is yeah I mean
I've I've tried not to follow it too
much but I do feel that yeah like I say
with any family
um any conflict is sad because Life's
Too Short yeah life well if you were in
the pub with them now what would you say
to them Life's Too Short you know just
slightly differences and you know just
just chat but I probably would never be
the pub with the two of them again you
never know you never know maybe you
never know I mean I think Harry owes you
a drink yeah just not a trash shots
H
um but yeah I don't I don't know I just
I mean he's gone from a digger to a gold
digger
yep you could like that
um I don't know like I said I I sit on
the fence I don't know the lady
um I wish him all the best I wish him
the happiest does he seem happy to you
um he's not the boy that I remember
that's for sure
but again I'm not in his shoes I have no
idea what's going on in his head I
haven't seen him for 21 years but you
know
you make your own happiness do you have
a view of Megan
I don't really know because I don't know
her um apart from obviously you know
what you hear or whatever but I'm
wondering if you think he's traded up
from you or down
definitely down
I don't know by the way I agree I don't
you should have stayed with someone like
you oh thank you he might have been a
lot happier I think yeah it'd been funny
yeah what do you think of King Charles
with the coronation coming in everything
I think it's amazing yeah yeah did you
ever meet him at the in those days yeah
I did obviously I can't really say too
much about it he did he was a lovely guy
yeah just to be clear you signed an MDA
have you worked as a groom at home I did
yeah like everybody who works there so
that's why you can't talk about your
employment no as a man how did you find
him in good hands with him as harmonic
yeah yeah he's yeah personally I think
he's a lovely guy yeah and I think same
as William I think you know you can ask
for anyone nicer really but that's my
own View and they treated me really well
what happens to you now but you you
talked about earlier about you know
going back under your rock is that what
you want to do yeah I kind of I think
this is a means to an end you know I
just it's done I don't have to worry
um you know when it all flares up
everyone knows it's done it's dusted I
can go back to living my normal little
life driving my diggers being happy and
not having to look over my shoulder and
opening my door one day and hundreds of
cameras being there I just I've always
been slightly in the back of your mind
it has I think as any mother would know
when you have little kids your
protective side comes out and I think to
to take control of this you have to come
out and control it because otherwise one
day you're just going to wake up and
you're going to have no control and you
know you've got this damage limitation
yes and I think you've limited the
damage extremely well actually hopefully
because you come over just as a decent
person yeah who didn't want any of this
had your privacy invaded again
ironically by the prince of privacy we
just saw a picture of you in the Digger
let's get that back up because
just don't look at you and think this is
someone who drives these monstrous
diggers yeah you obviously love it I do
I do I mean I worked as a groom for
quite a while and then obviously the
hours and stuff and dad has always done
groundworks and he kind of said to me
well I said Tim I didn't know what I
want to do anymore so you said well work
for me until you know what you want to
do
um and back then being a girl on site is
a little bit strange I can remember to
put my hair up and wear a coat
um but I love it I love it and I think
that you know it's a real opportunity
for other females to maybe
come out come and do building work it's
brilliant it's a great place to be
yeah what does it mean to you to be
British
I said a little bit at the start there
that to me someone like you represents
like old-fashioned British values you
know the the fact that you had dignity
and decency you didn't sell your story
you didn't betray this great secret that
you could do at any moment to me that's
kind of old-fashioned
um I mean I was brought up with you know
you work hard you play hard you know you
don't uh you don't look dirty laundry
and you know you mind your own business
um you don't get involved in something
that you don't want to get involved in
and I just think yeah I just I think
it's just where I've been brought up but
you're quite looking forward to going
back to relative anonymity again I am
yes yep I'm quite looking forward to
getting back in my degree I've been back
in that Pub no are you going to
um probably not
no probably not you must have had other
friends who knew nothing about this I've
now picked up the sun yeah and seen you
all over the front page you've got what
yeah I mean it's something I I rarely
talked about so obviously moving from
where I lived with my parents to where I
live now a lot of my friends would
wouldn't even know that I knew Harry or
you know had anything to do with the
royal family back then
um so for them it was a great shock when
they seen my picture that had flared up
when they were trying to find the lady
um and I was a little bit like oh yeah
that was many moons ago and then
suddenly now it's front page of
everything
um but you know what it's it's like
ripping a plaster off really yeah you
feel relieved in order it's done I don't
have to worry I don't have to worry that
people are going to turn up at my house
and start you know asking me questions
and I'm not ready for it I'm you know
it's done if Prince Harry is watching
this maybe in Montecito in his mansion
what would you say to him
I would say if you're about hook up
let's have a drink catch up chill out
whatever just be happy drink even drinks
flaming sambucas anymore I don't know
probably not looks like he needs one he
does yeah what do you think perhaps I
should take him a tray of shots and just
just talk it over I actually think he
needs a trail of sharks and he needs a
bit of old kind of West country Common
Sense ages yeah don't you think West
country happiness I feel I feel like he
needs a bit of straight talking from
someone who knew him in his old life
yeah I mean like I said I haven't seen
her for 21 years and I'd be more than
happy to sit down and talk it out but he
probably wouldn't want to know what
advice would you give him
just be happy life is too short and make
up pick your battles make you yeah
sometimes silence is better than nothing
but yeah we'll see well listen it's been
great to meet you yeah uh I didn't even
know who you were now we all know who
you are no I know and uh you're gonna
have to live with that it's a weird
thing to live with it is uh but you've
talked about it very I think with you
know great modesty and I completely
understand why you've decided to talk
out because otherwise it just happens
anyway right it is it's either you
control it or controls you and you know
this way it leaves everyone else Alone
um they know who it is job done Sasha
back to your Digger thank you it's
lovely to meet you and you and thank you
very much thank you well after the break
my reaction to a Sasha's interview with
my Royal pack so don't go anywhere
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
who took Prince Harry's virginity in a
field behind a pub
Sasha Walpole kept Harry Seeker for 21
years and then Harry told his truth in
his explosive Memoir that included her
so now as Sasha's turn to tell her truth
in a Global TV exclusive she'll join me
on Piers Morgan uncensored and I
guarantee the interview will last a
little longer than Harry did
[Music]
foreign
every little help for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Piers organization so
joining me now to discuss that
extraordinary interview is Vanity Fair's
Katie Nichols it sounds Matt Wilkerson
and author and historian Dr Tessa Dunlop
so Cody nickel
I mean it feels weird to be interviewing
a a woman about taking someone's
virginity yes there were some good
questions so let's start with that right
because it is a weird interview to be
doing at all but I I thought the reason
that she has come forward make complete
sense to me and I also felt there was a
kind of controlled anger really that her
privacy and this is so ironic had been
invaded by Harry without even a thought
really for the repercussions for her for
her having to be made public and so on
what did you make of it well I think
this is the first time when you got to
give Harry some credit because for me if
he was going to choose anyone to lose
his virginity with what a cracker of a
girl so she kept her secret yeah all
those years she was loyal she was
discreet she's been magnavino she's been
generous she didn't have a pop at him
she she says what we're all thinking
which is how can you be so hypocritical
and invade someone else's privacy whilst
invading your own but she does she did
it with such dignity one lovely girl so
actually I think I've got to take my
house off to Prince Harry because I
don't think he could have chosen a
battle a better girl to have lost his
virginity it is the text but way to lose
your virginity way better incidentally
than all his ancestors who had to
Vicarious means that they indulged in
during World War One and so forth much
better to have a hearty Bonk in a field
I mean I'm kind of wishing I could go
back and redo my own narrative we're all
thinking that is consensual friendship
bit of alcohol and and as for cutting
off the relationship I mean does anybody
stay in contact with their first shag
Pierce
for a while I don't think it was quite
as unceremonious as that yeah really but
but I know what you mean it is I mean it
is spectacularly awkward for a young man
the first time it happens particularly
if it's in that kind of situation and he
probably was just too embarrassed that
probably just to ever think about it
again well he was the first to raise it
of course of course it's amazing that
she was just sitting there on tabloid
gold for 20 20 odd years you know and
it's taking can Harry to actually
describe this liaison for her actually
to you know to come forward well for
Harry to cash in on it with his book
which is made in millions to cash in on
his virginity and invade the privacy of
the woman he had it with his other way
of describing it that's what he's done
it is breathtakingly hypocritical just
from a from a media perspective yeah no
it is I mean I'll say if we had got hold
of that story 20 odd years ago we would
have had a deluge of legal letters of
cool seem to be the first squealing
about it says I know you're in defend
him at all cost count but even you must
think it was a bit off yeah I mean are
bits of the book that hit some of the
wrong notes given the message she has
historically tried to push but lest we
forget that the agency in this narrative
Harry didn't name her he didn't name the
pub he didn't even describe it he had
named The Pub in other parts and there
was quite a lot of detail in there too I
mean
she was getting messages immediately
from all the local people at the time
who all knew it was her right and
there's quite a tight set normally a
polo lot they'd all sat on the secret
for a very long time so who is the third
party that really pushed this Downstream
it is and I'm sitting next to a tabloid
editor I'm I'm beside a former one and
here we have don't tell me it's the
media thought
oh well let's get in there before Prince
Harry does because his default position
is always when in doubt blame the media
we didn't say that the royal family
races the media said that
Harry is Harry has actually been the
biggest source of Royal news over the
last four or five months could you I
have not had to do any work he's just
sat there the biggest Royal gossip in
history has turned out to be the one
who's bleeded the most about privacy the
one who's breached the privacy of the
most amount of people when it comes to
the Royals and all the Royal Circle I
was with somebody at the weekend who's a
good friend of uh of some of the royal
family and have been with them and
apparently all Harry's Wider Circle of
Old Friends they're just completely
open-mouthed that for 20 years they like
Sasha have got out of their way to
protect him never giving interviews
hiding stories protecting him physically
on nights getting him out of clubs and
bars when he's in trouble and so on only
for him to then have all this stuff in
the book talking about taking drug with
people talking about getting this and
that and the other they're all open
mouth at what they see Tessa not this is
not me saying it I would anyway but what
they see is just complete hypocrisy I I
hear you there's complexities I think
complete hypocrisy and the idea is it
common it's true I think it is complex
and I think what was Charming about
Sasha and by the way I think the whole
nation is now thinking why couldn't it
just on the old-fashioned thing and
married yes
imagine if somebody will I know my mum
will be watching girls she was a lovely
girl why couldn't you marry someone like
that yeah if only
um but it's not binary there isn't
really a bad ill-goody in this story in
this actually I don't agree I don't
agree two consensual teenagers who had
sex and both in this particular story
right and both of them have made a bit
of money
actually I think rather charming and I
know that Sasha felt because she's a
decent stick my goodness there's
earthquakes and wars and why are we
talking about this and again I would
have to say that's a media gender but
actually it's a bit of Light Relief and
I refuse to say this is torture and
uncomfortable it's actually quite an
upbeat story you know in a weird way
it's kind of a Vindication a a way of
being modern and young and carefree well
that's one way of calling a pub bunk
well I mean look I I think we're
slightly over egging the defensive
souffle there I think the key challenge
I would make about Harry with this book
is that it goes against everything he
himself has railed against the media
because I put this to his camera what
they say is but this is on his terms
this is in his words this is on his
terms this is his chance to answer that
it's that whole reclaiming the narrative
story again and actually I think most
people think don't have a problem with
it but they might have a problem with it
had Sasha not been as generous as she
had been let's just say she had had a
problem with it let's just say it had
caused her big problems in her life then
I think we'd be sitting for example
I I was when you asked her that
I mean what if that had been the case
Harry didn't know no he had no idea
whether she well he didn't contact her
she said
name her name is
she could have said I'm not the old
woman I was only 18 do shut up it was a
quick stop no no I mean she could her
name her name was being passed to the
papers okay let's be clear you've named
it the papers
because Harry's argument is it was like
half a zoo half Truman Show we were
discussing this and actually this one
innocuous paragraph on his losses not
innocuous to say has led to a Truman
Show all of us are talking about a bonk
a teenage Matt I want to bring in uh
just the wider picture we're heading
towards the coronation and putting aside
The Virginity story to one thing I think
it exposes the hypocrisy but I also
agree with Tessa that in a way it
doesn't really matter Sasha seems
completely well adjusted to buy it she
told everyone he needed to know no one's
going said there are more important
things in the world agree with me almost
almost but let's talk about the wider
story about Harry's we head towards this
this coronation which is coming up fast
I'm only a few weeks away from it it's
going to be a glorious celebration on
one level but we still don't know
whether Harry and Megan are going to be
sitting there amongst a family they've
spent the last two years now trashing on
the global stage well it's the thing
it's got to be the Charles and
Commercial it can't be the Harry and
Megan circus but if they're there it
will be but I think they will need
reassurances that Harry isn't going to
do any more interviews between now and
May the 6th what about afterwards with
all the information here I mean this is
a guy remember the thing that shocked me
about the book was not all the trivial
stuff at all it was the fact that even
at Prince Philip's funeral he's
revealing intensely private
conversations with William and Charles
to the world against their wishes or
they didn't know anything about this
they'd have definitely said no and yet
he expects to be at the coronation from
what I've read sitting amongst them
again having conversations how would
they trust him I wouldn't trust a family
member in that situation it's
interesting because I take up with tests
on here because um although Sasha came
out has come out and told her story but
there's plenty of other people like
William like Charles uh like like
cressido his ex-girlfriend I think he's
speaking about other people in this book
that haven't come out and spoken like
William hasn't come out and defended
himself have been able to defend himself
against things or his wife or against
the against it I mean and also what
about that poor matron I mean I really
did feel for her actually tested because
we don't even know if that matron at his
prep school is alive or dead or whether
she's got family who are around who may
have read this but it was so hurtful the
way he talked about that matron and so
like again I come back to the hypocrisy
this is a guy portraying himself as this
be kind feminist basically taking down a
defenseless matron for her looks really
I mean it was unpleasant wasn't it yeah
it was it was unkind it was it was
unkind and misogynist actually yeah and
and you know we're sort of seeing the
the new the new look feminist Harry and
that is really quite coronation or not
look I I think he has to be I mean I've
said the two before because I think that
I think there has to be that I think
that's just to be that United fan as I
said to you before and I'll say it to
Tess as well just because Charles may
feel obliged to invite him because it's
his son and he feels guilty probably
about what's gone on before with him and
Camilla and Diner and so on as
coronation peers yes but that's the key
point it's not just Charles's coronation
it's not a private family event it's a
publicly funded event and actually it's
the people's coronation of their King
and that's where I have a problem as one
of the subjects right because then he
goes back in here I don't want to see
these two money Grabbers anywhere near
it but you are a subject with a very
light voice you have a big platform and
they're coming from you not exactly a
shrinking violence and there are plenty
of other subjects in this what should be
a broad shouldered impartial monarchy
yeah but you know as well as I do if
they turn up at this thing it's all
going to be about Megan and Harry it
depends
if they're not there and they stay in
California actually focus goes together
now Matt will agree with me here it'll
be the Press won't it that make Harry
would you know what I'll go back over
the things then so when he came back for
the Duke of edinburgh's funeral we know
he kind of he didn't pay himself very
well because he had an argument with his
father and his brother you know just
hours after after the funeral he came up
for the Jubilee He was put on the side
and he basically behaved himself and
stayed away and then at the funeral he
he was he was on he was on good behavior
so if they can follow that blueprint
then maybe won't want to appear a child
there she won't want to appear
churlished you have to remember that
actually it is the people's coronation
of their King right it's not a private
family event and I think a lot of
British people will share my view that
they shouldn't be there sorry you trash
your family that badly that egregiously
and you trash the monarchy and you
damage it all the poll ratings for all
the Royals have been taken a heavy dent
in America which is a key place for the
monarchy for its future all taken a hit
because of this book and you've just
answered your own question if you want
to reach outside of Britain's borders
they've got to be there how is it going
to play to America oh we're not inviting
the house of Montecito it would make us
look so mely House of Monty's I just
said that to annoy you do me were you
all right you've succeeded in the house
of bloody Montecito it's gonna listen I
think if if he's not there it'll it will
overshadow the event and I think you
know maybe there will be maybe there
will be a neat compromise let's not
forget it I think it's Archie's fourth
birthday on that day it would be a very
neat solution for Megan to stay at home
with the children perhaps not be there
and I think it perhaps be more palatable
people okay
I appreciate it and Matt thank you lucky
stars I didn't ask you where you lost
your virginity it's not tempted I did in
the green room still waiting we've had
that conversation good to see you that's
it for me next week there'll be a
special guest or two of my seat as I'm
off interviewing criminals I'm back on
February the 20th from New York City
with some big guests there so whatever
you're up to Keep It Uncensored good
night
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
virginity in a field behind a pub
Sasha Walpole kept Harry Seeker for 21
years and then Harry told his truth in
his explosive Memoir and that included
her so now Sasha's turn to tell her
truth
and a Global TV exclusive she'll join me
on peace